today on the Matt wall show former NBA
star Dwyane Wade has been parading his
trans kid quote unquote around like a
pet for two years now but a new report
reveals that the boy's mother is not on
board with this transition and she
believes that Wade is doing it for money
and attention imagine that also the
media comes up with its most absurd
argument against voter ID yet the White
House tries to defend its secret social
media censorship campaign Caitlyn Jenner
and Dylan Mulvaney get into a fight and
nobody wins and a priest in Ireland is
thrown under the bus by his own Bishop
when he dares to defend Catholic
teaching during mass and you can't do
that all of that and more today on the
Matt Walsh show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
inside every Progressive is a
totalitarian screaming to get out and
the team at front page magazine they've
been unmasking these totalitarians since
the earliest days of the internet
founded by David Horowitz a former red
diaper baby and new leftist who
ultimately became an enemy of the left
and a best-selling author front page
magazine has spent over two decades
combating the radical left's efforts to
destroy America there are two new
podcasts the right take with Mark tapson
and the Jason Hill show offer riveting
interviews and insightful coverage of
politics culture and current events the
right take with Mark Mark tapson uh
offers a fascinating in-depth cultural
commentary as well as interviews with
well-known conservative thinkers like
Heather McDonald uh Michael Walsh and
many others the Jason Hill show offers
thoughtful deep Dives about the
ideologies of the radical left and
intellectuals interviews with
intellectuals like Peter wood and Bruce
Gilley it takes a village to combat the
radical less efforts to destroy America
that's why as a fan of my show you
should also check out uh these guys over
at front page magazine you won't regret
it go to frontpagemag.com
Dwyane Wade reached the end of his NBA
career back in 2020 he had faded from
the spotlight during the previous few
years bouncing from Team to team
averaging about 11 points a game towards
the end which isn't great in the NBA for
his position just so you know when he
finally hobbled into retirement he faced
the terrifying Prospect of irrelevance
and it was at this exact moment when
conveniently his 12 year old son came
out as transgender it's a very similar
situation to like when Colin Kaepernick
was right at the moment he got benched
he decided to become a social justice
Advocate and for Dwyane Wade right at
the moment when he washed out of the NBA
he decided that he was going to do the
same couldn't have planned it any better
really the moment his MBA career ended
he was able to make the jump into the
very profitable business of social
justice activism
in fact his supposedly trans son who he
now calls his daughter
um brought him more attention and
generated more headlines than he was
ever able to achieve on his own even
during his prime playing days
so here's Wade just to just to reminisce
for a moment here's wade back in 2020
announcing his son's new identity to the
World on The Ellen Degeneres Show watch
so once Zaya 12 year old came home and
first Zion everybody I don't know if
everyone knows originally named Zion
Zion born as a boy came home and said
hey uh so I want to talk to you guys you
know I think going forward I'm ready to
live my truth and I want to be a
referenced as she and her I would love
for you guys to call me Zaya and so
internally now is our job to one go out
and get information to reach out to
every relationship that we have my wife
reached out to everybody on the the cast
of pose
um we're just trying to figure out as
much information we can to make sure
that we give our child the best
opportunity to be you know her best self
that's his job as a parent he says his
son comes home one day announces that
he's really a girl and his job as a
father he claims is to immediately
accept this statement as fact ask no
follow-up questions uh and follow the
lead of the child blindly and without a
hint of skepticism not only that but the
father's next task is to apparently go
on national television and announce his
12 year old's gender identity to the
entire world this is an important part
of the affirmation process you see not
only do you unquestionably affirm
whatever he says but you also have to
put it on a billboard for the whole
world to see
so that this identity that your child
just adopted five seconds ago will now
be set in stone cemented in place
from this point Wade would go on to
become a prominent advocate of trans
rights and everywhere he went he would
be greeted with Applause and adulation
you know he was just a washed up NBA
player before he was facing a life as a
as an ESPN commentator which is a lowly
fate that anyone would be desperate to
avoid but now with his trans child he
found himself accepted celebrated
beloved in the upper echelons of society
in Hollywood here he is on the red
carpet earlier this year
and I just have to thank you because
you've been amazing with your daughter
it's pretty incredible what keeps you
going fighting for her
um just been you know just being a
father and just seeing my child grow up
every day and doing what she's supposed
to do as a parent is to make sure that
you sit back and you know you see what
it is in life that they want to do and
you try to go there with them and try to
help them mold them into what it is they
want to be and who they want to be so
we're just doing our part you know as
parents and uh we love our kids and we
get to see them every day that's what
people on the outside don't get to see
but we know them and we see them all the
time yeah and we believe them when they
tell us who they are what do you say to
a dad out there whose daughter has just
come home and said I'm trans what do you
say to that Dad well I say the moment
when you were in the hospital when you
grabbed your daughter and you looked at
your daughter and all the things that
went through your mind all emotions that
went through your mind and how much love
fills your heart at that moment don't
let that ever leave you no matter what
like the one thing is parents when we do
is we find our mini me's and we try to
make them just like us we just
understand like our kids are going to be
who they are it's our job to help mold
them and help try to you know push them
in the right places that they want to go
but just remember that moment what you
said in that hospital that day they were
born
yes Dwayne remember that moment in the
hospital when your son was born your son
the doctor identified him by you know by
his sex all human beings are identified
this way and and that's who he was and
that's who he still is so remember that
moment take your own advice at least
that part of your advice the rest of it
is nonsense he says that the job of a
father is to and I quote
sit back and see what they want to do
and go there with them now I'm not
exaggerating when I say that this is the
worst parenting advice I have ever heard
in my entire life
it is quite literally the opposite of
parenting you know a great way to parent
would be to listen to what Dwyane Wade
is saying and just adopt the opposite
approach just do do the reverse of
whatever the hell he is babbling about
because if I parented the way that he
proposes all of my kids would be dead
right now none of them would have made
it past the age of two if I sat back and
went wherever they wanted to go and did
whatever they want to do
if that's how you're going to parent
then you aren't needed you might as well
just abandon your kids in a forest
somewhere let them fend for themselves
maybe they'll be adopted by a friendly
pack of wolves honestly Dwyane Wade's
kids would have been better off Raised
by Wolves than raised by him you know an
actual parent a real parent is there to
offer guidance and wisdom and insight
and Direction and correction that's the
job of a parent that is what you are
there for and if your son comes up to
you one day and reveals that he's
confused about his identity
he is in desperate need of guidance and
wisdom and insight and Direction and
correction
but he wasn't given what he was needed
instead his confusion was Affirmed
and then exploited
and that's certainly the case that the
boy's mother Wade's ex-wife is making
now in court filings from the
post-millennial this was uh breaking
news yesterday it says Wade's ex claims
that Wade has been exploiting ziya Who
quote came out as transgender at the age
of 12. Siobhan fuchess Wade has now
filed paperwork to ask a judge to hold
off on the legal name change saying that
ziya's modeling contracts and influencer
deals are Wade's impetus for forging
ahead with the gender transition in the
legal filing food just Wade States quote
I have concerns that Dwayne may be
pressuring our child to move forward
with the name and gender change in order
to capitalize on the financial
opportunities that he has received from
companies Wade who has had full custody
since 2011 with the divorce with future
swade went through said in August when
petitioning for the name change that the
child's mother was only informed as a
courtesy funchess Wade fought for four
years to retain custody of the children
she wants Zaya to wait until the age of
18 before making this change she is the
child of both Wade's oldest children and
is concerned that ziya is being
pressured into the changes by the Elder
Wade who is quote poised to profit from
ziya's deals and sex change to back up
her claims fungus Wade said that she had
a conversation with Wade in April during
which he explained the extent of the
financial benefits of Zaya's sex change
she said quote he told me that he
intended to make our child very famous
due to the name and gender issue and
also informed me that there would be
endorsements and contracts associated
therewith
I am concerned she went on uh that our
child is being commercialized at a young
age and also is of the uncontrollable
consequences of media exposure I.E cyber
bullying statements and or pictures
taken out of context of our child and
The Unwanted Spotlight focused on our
child
so in other words Dwyane Wade is an
abusive
evil monster and none of this is new in
fact uh the Dwyane Wade case is is quite
instructive
you know it's it's a symptomatic of
something which is like and it raises a
question which is why is it
that celebrities are so prone to having
trans kids have you noticed that how do
you explain the high concentration of
trans kids quote unquote in Hollywood
Dwyane Wade Charlize Theron uh Jamie Lee
Curtis Jennifer Lopez Busy Phillips the
list goes on
it's because uh they use their kids as
status symbols and there is no way
around that conclusion
in fact
even if it happened to be true that a
kid could be quote trans and that their
transgenderism should be affirmed and
both of those things are emphatically
not true at all but even if it was they
would still be totally indefensible to
make your child's gender transition
public
there's no benefit to your child and
turning this into a public spectacle if
he's on a gender Journey as you say and
if you actually wanted to give him space
to be who he is as you claim then you
wouldn't be crowding the space with
cameras and microphones
the only possible effect of the
publicity is to set this new identity in
place
now that you've made them into a leader
right into an LGBT icon and you've got
the endorsement deals rolling in and
there's a lot of money on the line
and not only that but in Dwyane Wade's
son's case like he's making all this
money Dwyane Wade doesn't have a job
anymore and so what now I guess he's the
breadwinner in the family he's going to
feel like he's not able to switch back
or detransition or have a change of
heart
and that of course is exactly why they
do this
they are leading their children it turns
out
you know I wish that Dwyane Wade was
merely sitting back passively and
following his child's lead that would be
bad parenting but not as bad as what
he's actually doing
because what he's actually doing is
actively leading his son
into self-rejection self-loathing
deeper and deeper confusion
he has taken his son by his hand and
guided him straight over the cliff
and profited from it the whole way down
it is again Pure Evil
he should be shamed for it and disgraced
for it
ostracized from society arrested
you know this because this is abuse
but instead all he hears is Applause
now let's get to our five headlines
do you have a mystery smell in your home
that you uh just can't get rid of you've
tried candles and cover-up sprays but
nothing seems to work the best-selling
Eden Pure thunderstorm air purifier uses
proven oxy technology that quickly seeks
out and destroys any odor whether it be
for litter boxes trash cans dirty
diapers or cooking smells even if you
don't know where the smell is coming
from the thunderstorm will get rid of it
in just a minute unlike candles and
cover sprays the thunderstorm doesn't
just mask or cover up bad odors it
completely eliminates them best of all
the thunderstorm doesn't require any
separate purchase of a filter it plugs
directly into the wall so as to not take
up any floor space it's compact it's got
a great design for traveling right now
you can save 200 on an Eden Pure
thunderstorm three pack for your whole
home protection you'll get three units
for under 200 you get all of that you
can put one in your basement bedroom
family kitchen anywhere you need fresh
clean air so go to eat in pure that's
edenpuredeals.com use codemat3 to get
three units for under two hundred
dollars that's edenpuredeals.com
discount code matt3 to save two hundred
dollars and shipping is free
all right I want to start here just for
uh a nice laugh we are um very much in
the throw anything against against the
wall phase of the election season we've
been in that phase for
I mean like a decade or something and so
here is NBC warning about voter ID laws
and how they might disproportionately
impact
wait for it trans people
let's listen
Ms gen Z gears up to hit the polls
transgender voters are concerned they
might be blocked from casting their
ballots yeah that's because a growing
number of states are enforcing stricter
voter identification laws that
disproportionately impact the Community
NBC out reporter Joe your Caba joins us
now with more on this Joe good morning
to you so first of all how can voter ID
laws create obstacles for transgender
people and where do we see some of the
strictest voter ID laws
sure yes so voter ID law is
disproportionately impact trans people
because trans people are more likely to
have IDs without the name that they go
by and the gender marker that reflects
how they present and Recent research
shows that just over 200 000 eligible
trans voters in 31 states that both
conduct their elections mostly in person
and require or request ID at the polls
don't have IDs that reflect their gender
identities and the names they go by
um and you know the states that have the
strictest voter ID laws are mostly
concentrated in the South and Midwest so
you're you know Tennessee Wisconsin
Kansas so voters there are going to be
most affected
hmm yeah this is a fun game you know
just spin the wheel and find out what
trans people are disproportionately
impacted by throw a dart at the board
and uh you know trans people are just
partially impacted by car accidents
trans people are disproportionately
impacted by tornadoes trans people are
disproportionately impacted by uh
falling into volcanoes trans people are
disproportionately impacted by Death
because when a trans person dies they're
really super dead as opposed to when
other people die and they're less dead
so trans people are just personally
impacted by everything and this is even
sillier considering that you can
actually change your gender and your
name on your driver's license in all 50
states you shouldn't be able to do that
okay if I was in charge you would not be
able to do that but you can so you can
actually do that so what we're talking
about here are lazy trans people who
want to identify as a different name and
a different gender but don't feel like
filing the paperwork like they don't
feel like going to the DMV
um but they also want to retain the
right to be offended when they have to
show their ID and uh somebody uh sees
their biological gender on it
even though they chose not to change it
they could do it they just don't feel
like it because they're lazy and and and
that's uh that now becomes a violation
of their rights
but I do appreciate this because it
highlights once again how just
completely absurd
the voter ID complaints actually are
um the left has not been able to come up
with an argument against showing your ID
to vote they're against it but they
don't know why at least they don't have
a public-facing argument I mean they do
know why they're against it they're
against it because uh their their post
to voter ID because voter ID makes it
harder to cheat and that's why they
don't want it I mean that is that's that
is really the only reason you could be
against it is if
you you want to cheat and it's going to
make it harder for you to do so but they
can't they can't make that argument
publicly and so maybe eventually they
will we might get to the point where
they are openly defending cheating
because on the basis that it's the only
way to save democracy
so we're not quite at that point yet so
they can't say that so that so instead
they're left with arguing that um black
people don't know how to get driver's
licenses and don't know where the DMV is
and have no way to figure it out and the
trans people are traumatized by having
to present an ID that they didn't feel
like taking the time to change
and it's also a part of this very
familiar pattern of trans people acting
victimized by their own choices so the
trans person says well I have uh I
identify as a female but it says but I
haven't but my ID says male and it'll
make me feel bad to have to present that
what am I supposed to do well I I don't
know that's that I mean that's your
problem that's your fault that's that's
your own choice there's like a series of
choices that have led you you chose that
to try to identify as a different sex
you chose not to get your your ID
changed and now that's our problem like
now we can't protect the Integrity of
our voting process because of this
problem that you created for yourself
how is that my issue it's the same thing
when you hear from trans people that say
well you know someone a trans person
a man let's say who
uh thinks anyway that he's passing as a
female and because maybe he's gotten
surgery or whatever and then says well
look at me you think that I should have
to go into the men's restroom how am I
going to go into the men's restroom
looking like this
I don't that's your that was your choice
that's that's not my problem
I don't know what to tell you you made
the choice to you got the surgery you're
dressing the way you dress that's all
your decision and so you yes you have
not put yourself in an awkward spot when
it comes to the bathrooms because you
don't belong in the women's bathroom
um but it would be a little conspicuous
in the men's bathroom
I don't know what to tell you it's not
my problem and it's not the problem it
shouldn't be the problem of the actual
women who are in their restrooms and
don't want a man in there
so you're going to people who have
nothing to do with the choices you made
and expecting them to solve a problem
that you created for yourself
that's just not how it works or at least
it's not how it should it shouldn't work
that way anyway
all right some news on the Free Speech
front Elon Musk has given more details
about his plans for Content moderation
you tweeted this talk to Civil Society
leaders Jonathan Greenblatt Yale
eisenstadt Rashad Robinson Jessica
Gonzalez Norman Chen Derek Johnson Ken
Hersh and Sydney benavidez about how
Twitter will continue to combat hate and
harassment and enforce its election
Integrity policies Twitter will not
allow anyone who was de-platformed for
violating Twitter rules back on the
platform until we have a clear process
for doing so which will take at least a
few more weeks Twitter's content
moderation Council will include
Representatives with widely Divergent
views which will certainly include the
Civil Rights community and groups who
face hate-fueled violence
okay I'm not
I'm not going to claim that the Elon
Musk takeover of Twitter is a bust at
this point
he just got in there
um it's very early right we need to give
him time to figure it out so
I can understand all that
but this also isn't a good sign maybe we
could say um it is a it's a bad sign
because he had a little group chat about
content moderation and hate-fueled
violence
every single person in the conversation
was a leftist every single one and not
just like
we're not talking about uh Bill
maher-esque liberals okay we're talking
about far left every single one included
these are people with the ADL the NAACP
other leftist advocacy groups
so he says widely Divergent views but
the views uh that that are in that group
there they diverge on the spectrum
between extremely left-wing and really
really extremely left wing like that's
that's the the spectrum of Divergent
views that he's
has assembled so far
and that is um
that's pretty concerning
now again still early
but it's something we should keep an eye
on
and you know if you really want to hear
about the impact of harassment and hate
and um uh death threats and all of that
on the platform then you need to talk to
conservatives and especially in
particular you need to talk to
conservatives who have faced the Wrath
of the trans activists because the trans
activists are
Far and Away without even a close second
the most vicious and vile people on
social media
um and there is just no rule of decency
or in no law that they respect or will
abide by they just do not care about any
of that
I know this from experience
um
and and you know it's like people are
always talking about the the you know
people always talking about death
threats anytime a leftist says anything
it's a little bit of criticism I'm doing
death threats all over the place and you
know maybe in some cases they're right
but I think very often this is
exaggerated
what I can tell you though is that death
threats death wishes you know things
like that doxing and all that when I
talk about that from the trans activist
I'm it is 100 not an exaggeration this
is just it is guaranteed to happen when
you go up against these people so
if you're really interested
in having a uh having a full
conversation about this problem you need
to bring people in who've experienced
that part of it
and so far he hasn't but hopefully he
does meanwhile the White House responded
to The Intercept report about DHS using
social media companies to suppress
speech and I guess we could call this a
response such as it is here it is
there was a reporting in The Intercept
about
opportunities for the federal government
to identify for social media companies
different posts that contains uh what
was perceived as misinformation about
the origins of covid the vaccine other
things as well you know such as Ukraine
or the US withdrawal from Afghanistan
yeah so um look I'll say this um the the
administration the Biden Administration
remains fully committed to our mission
to protect the security and resilience
of our um of of our you know elections
at Safeguard election infrastructure
that includes combat combating
disinformation that is something that we
are committed to you know we work to
protect that uh protect Americans from
disinformation that threatens the
Homeland including malicious efforts
spread by Foreign adverse
adversaries
adversaries sorry pardon me began before
the disinformation governance board was
established in fact some of that work
began before this Administration so you
know I want I want to be very clear that
cross-agency work continues to this day
I don't want to don't want to get ahead
of of anything else this is a Department
of Homeland Security so I would refer
you to them so you are flagging
misinformation I don't have anything
more to ad this is a Department of
Homeland Security that I refer to
adversaries gotta watch out for them God
dang adversaries
you know we've talked plenty about why
the government shouldn't be in the
business of uh policing what it deems
misinformation or disinformation
but I want to point out one other thing
which which I'm not sure if if we've
really taken note of to the extent that
we should
so you note it notice the confidence on
the left
they want to give the government and
governmental agencies this this power
over information to decide to decide
what is misinformation disinformation
and then to suppress it
which is just a a profound uh Power that
they want to Grant the government the
government's already granted itself this
power
so they want to do this
and they're not worried
about what will happen if Republicans
take over the government they're not
worried about if Republicans win in 2024
I mean think about that they they tell
us that Donald Trump is uh is a is an
existential threat to democracy as a
fascist he's Hitler and all these things
and they're also very worried that it'll
run and win in 2024
and yet at the same time they are
expanding every moment the the scope and
power of the federal government
knowing that Donald Trump might be in
charge of that in a couple of years
so how do you how do you make sense of
that
they aren't worried about these Powers
being used against them why is that well
for one thing for all their talk about
fascism
you know they actually know that
Republicans wouldn't do many of the
things that they do
okay so they they know that even if
Republicans could
they wouldn't go behind the scenes to
social media companies and give them a
list of leftist talking points and
leftist ideas that they want erased from
the internet they they know that
Republicans aren't going that they know
that's the kind of thing that only they
will do
so that's part of their confidence the
other thing though is that they know
that they
has left us are so deeply embedded into
the system into the government into
these agencies
that it doesn't matter who's in the
white house or who's in Congress they
know that
I mean we we saw that in 2016 through
2020 with Donald Trump
you know he had the entire federal
government against him
and so it almost didn't really matter
what he did or what he said it's while
they were doing all their hand ringing
and being chicken littles running around
saying the sky is falling it actually
didn't like matter that much
and then when Donald Trump left
whatever whatever
I can't even say that we've made that
much progress was even made but whatever
progress was made it was all just
reversed immediately so it's just four
years wiped out about five seconds
partly through executive orders and also
partly just because the the federal
agencies were always in the hands of the
Democrats
the only thing they couldn't reverse of
the Supreme Court picks although they
would like to they're trying to
dilute that by expanding the court or
abolish the Supreme Court any of this
nonsense that's the only thing they
couldn't take about it everything else
just oh it's gone just like that
and and they know that and so that's
that's the confidence that they that
they have
all right I haven't mentioned anything
about this there's this maybe you've
heard about this cat fight between two
uh males Dylan Mulvaney and Caitlyn
Jenner a little background on this
milvaney did and I'm not even going to
play it for you because even I have my
limits for the grotesque things that
I'll subject you to but he did one of
his grotesque ridiculous days of
girlhood videos
where he talked about going to the store
in tight pants and having a bulge you
know because he has a penis because he's
a man
um uh he wants to be a woman but his
penis was visible through his shorts and
this is what he was doing a video about
this
and he said that um
this is why we have to normalize the
Bulge for women that was his uh that's
his you know campaign slogan that's the
banner that he's marching under now
Jenner responded to this by saying let's
not normalize any of what this person is
doing this is absurdity
and then in a follow-up he said he's
talking about his penis
which I mean pointed to the obvious
there thanks for that Jenner now this
led to lots of outrage on the left and
uh you know because Jenner is calling it
absurd but also because generic quote
misgendered Dylan Mulvane referred to
him as a guy
um and Mulvaney responded to that we'll
play a little bit of of uh this this is
this one's a little bit safer I don't
think he starts talking about his bulge
here but you never know with this guy so
let's watch a little bit of this
days of transitioning and remember being
embarrassed about your body or having
strangers give you dirty looks that's
why I made that video because I was
embarrassed and I wanted to reclaim my
body in a positive way and now you've
taken that and you've turned it into
something really ugly
and I didn't start days of girlhood
because being a woman sounded fun I
started this series because of the
unspoken shame of being newly trans I
still have so much to learn
and we come from very different
generations and you're so much farther
along in your journey than I am but I
have cheered you on from the second you
came out truly and I'm so happy that
you've had the surgeries that you've
desired but I'm 25 years old and I am on
day 233 I can't even get bottom surgery
right now if I wanted to I haven't been
on hormones long enough
and this whole situation makes me not
want to share my surgical plans because
there are so many trans women who don't
have access to it or they don't want it
and it doesn't make them any less of a
woman you know funny enough one of the
only things that we do have in common is
that I'm going to one of your surgeons
you know I'm just I'm not as far along
as you please be patient
and you know now that I think about it I
I don't even think I have interest in
getting to know you because the way you
use your platform to publicly degrade me
it it told me everything I needed to
know about you and a trans person
invalidating another trans person's
transness is pretty evil in my eyes like
the call is coming from inside the house
it's coming off very selfish you know is
no one else allowed to be trans I for
one am excited to welcome anyone into
our community because I know how
isolating it can be in this whole
situation it feels like the movie Mean
Girls I mean Halloween is right around
the corner so there's a costume idea for
us I guess I don't know I digress but
you've been accepted like you've been
accepted by a group of people that
clearly does not accept me and nearly
every day
uh yeah it's very isolating it's very
isolating for for Dylan Mulvaney to be a
girl
supposedly for 45 seconds and uh to be
greeted with you know adulation and
Applause and corporate sponsorships and
brand deals and and you know invited to
speak at Women's Summits very very it's
very I feel very isolating and alone
no isolating alone to be an actual woman
Maybe
I could I could see that as being
isolated making you feel isolated and
lonely when when you're an actual woman
and you've been living as one because
you are one your entire life
and then this guy comes along and just
jumps to the front of every single line
well yesterday Jenna responded by
apologizing for misgendering Mulvaney he
tweeted an individual on Miss Jenner's
team haphazardly misgendered Dylan in
the Tweet he is talking about his penis
for this we deeply regret the comment
and have taken the appropriate actions
to rectify the situation internally Miss
Jenner has no further comment on the
matter and stands by her statements
otherwise
right someone on his team
well he is on his own team so I guess
that's accurate
you see
um
once again this is why Caitlyn Jenner
never should have been embraced by
conservatives because that's the real
like story here and I and I've seen some
conservatives responders defending
Jenner
he deserves no defense
really this is a story about the [ __ ]
conservatives the idiots who Embrace
this guy
and they just look dumber and dumber
every single day
never should have been embraced by
conservatives he is not a good Advocate
on this issue or on any issue but
especially on this one
okay to use the leftist terminology he
is not an ally
so these idiot conservatives think well
if we have a trans person come in and
criticize the trans agenda well that
that that's the trump card right there
that's the ace up our sleeves
no that's that's the last person who can
criticize the trans agenda is someone
who's actively promoting it
you know what it's like it's like um if
you want to do a News segment if you
want to do a television segment about
the problems of drunk driving and so you
have someone come on the air who is
currently drunk and drove to the studio
and you have him come on to talk about
the danger of drunk driving
that is the worst Advocate or that's the
worst person to talk about this issue
especially if he's talking about it by
you know you have this this drunk
bastard coming on uh criticizing other
drunk people
okay this is not someone you want to you
you want to have if you want someone to
to come on TV and you know stall the
virtues of moderation
it shouldn't be an actively drunk person
now you want to bring someone on who is
a recovering alcoholic used to be an
alcoholic has has gotten past it and is
recovering and can talk about
retrospectively talk about uh what it
was like to be an alcoholic you know as
someone who experienced it and got past
it that's different
just like if you want to talk about if
you want you want to talk about the
transgender agenda
yeah and bring on a d-trans person
someone who was in that life and managed
to get out of it and can talk about it
again retrospectively
um well that's a great advocate
but not someone who is actively in it
right now
and promoting it which Jenner is
refers to himself in the Tweet is Miss
Jenner
because you know what you're putting the
other side in a position where they're
right what Dylan Mulvaney said there
most of that is like basically right
from from from Caitlyn Jenner's
perspective he's right about that
because basically what he's saying is
wait a second if you get to be a woman
like why can't I
like where do you come off calling me a
he and yet you expect us to call you she
how does that work
he's he's actually right about that
that's what a brilliant Advocate Caitlyn
Jenner is he puts us in a position where
we have to he gets into an argument with
a guy like Dylan Mulvaney and Dylan
Mulvaney is right he put He gives this
this
be careful the words I use he gives this
individual the opportunity to be right
about something
that's how terrible Caitlyn Jenner is
that's not going to stop it yeah he's a
Fox News controller he's gonna stop Fox
from bringing him on
the worst possible person
all right
uh
what else do we got there's a few other
things we have to get to the comment
section in a second
um
I also wanted to maybe I'll mention this
uh Yahoo has this story it says we've
heard a little bit about Happy Meals
recently there's been a little bit of
Happy Meal talk on the show for whatever
reason Happy Meals have entered the
culture War
not that I want them to but that's just
the way that it's worked out
so Yahoo reports hot on the heels of the
boo buckets promotion McDonald's
announced the release of its new Happy
Meal toys figurines based off characters
from Black Panther wakanda forever which
heads to theaters November 11th there
are 10 toys in total all of them
characters from the new Marvel movie uh
these might seem like ordinary toys
but they continue a quiet theme that has
run through all of the fast food chains
recent promotions representation
very important it's very important to be
represented by a Happy Meal toy because
that's what we all
look for in life
you know that's what we want to see
that's how we find our own Guiding Light
in life is in a Happy Meal box and it
can be very traumatic when you pull the
toy out of the Happy Meal box and you
don't see yourself reflected in it
that's what I want when I get a Happy
Meal for my children I want to make sure
that I am personally reflected
in the Happy Meal toys themselves
in its announcement of the new Happy
Meal toys McDonald's explains that the
wakanda forever lineup gives everyone
the chance to see and celebrate their
inner hero the first Black Panther movie
set a whole new standard of
representation on screen and now we're
excited to bring that experience to our
restaurants and help fans see and
celebrate their inner hero with this new
Happy Meal toy because seeing is
believing Jesus
first of all why I I cannot understand
I'm being somewhat
rhetorical when I say that but
why are we pretending that black panther
was like the first movie with black
people in it it is this this desperate
attempt to turn it into some kind of um
uh some kind of historically significant
glass ceiling breaking moment
what have have you seen no movies in the
last 40 years what are you talking about
it's not even the first black superhero
so what it what is the significance here
exactly
foreign
and then on top of that too it's just
you see how like everything
is designed to encourage narcissism
you know it's like you can't enjoy
anything for its own sake anymore it's
always about yourself even right down to
damned Happy Meal toys and stupid
superhero movies
because what what's the marketing
promotion here it's well it's all about
celebrating you and your inner hero why
why would black panther be about
celebrating you or your inner hero isn't
black panther about the character black
panther aren't you watching it to see
that story unfold
but no you're actually watching it so
that you can see yourself as the hero on
the screen it's really all about you so
you're not enjoying a story anymore no
one enjoys the story
um because really it's all about
themselves and when you watch a movie
it's like you want to really you're just
staring into a your reflection in the
mirror
Everything is Everything is focused back
to the self
um it's just uh
every part of it is ridiculous but at
least as far as I know that these are
these are happy meals for kids anyway so
they've gotten away from the adult Happy
Meal thing although I'm sure there are
plenty of adults who go and disgrace
themselves by buying these things uh
let's get to the comment section
man it's required that you grow a beard
hey we're the sweet baby gang
uh let's see hi I've been watching your
daily wire show for a while today was no
exception you rightfully canceled Ann
Hathaway but I want to offer this as a
concept when I was a state
representative we debated abortion I
posed a question the other side couldn't
answer if you're wrong on abortion what
does that get you and if I'm wrong what
happens of course the answer is if I'm
wrong you have a beautiful baby
yeah this is what I've called the
Pascal's wager of the abortion debate
you know
um because uh it's if we are wrong
about the abortion issue
and we succeed in stopping abortion in
many places which we have
then the end result of our wrongness is
that lots of people are living who would
not otherwise have been allowed to live
that's that's the end result of us being
wrong it's also the end result of us
being right
but if the other side is wrong right the
end result is that millions of human
beings are dead if they're right so if
the pro-abortion side is right then that
that means that a bunch of clumps of
cells were discarded and it doesn't mean
anything if they're right which they
aren't but if they were
but what I'm saying is if they're wrong
the consequence of their wrongness is
Mass Slaughter on an unthinkable scale
so worst case for the pro-life side if
they're wrong is that there's a whole
bunch of people that are that lived and
wouldn't
worst case scenario on the pro-abortion
side is that you've got uh you've got
the Holocaust times 10 you know that's
happened over the last several decades
and this argument is important because
even the most hard-line pro-abortion
people will usually admit a certain
amount of uncertainty they don't know
when life begins they're not going to
say when it begins they won't answer
that question and they always just
remember Barack Obama infamously said
it's above my pay grade dance that
question they all give an answer similar
to that which means that even according
to them they could be wrong which means
that they buy their own logic they at
least could be
supporting promoting encouraging the
Mass Slaughter of human beings
which would be reason enough to be
pro-life
that's that's the interesting point here
is that you don't eat you don't need to
have a firm answer on when life begins
to be firmly pro-life now I do have a
firm answer but you don't need to
all you need to know is that it's at
least
plausible that life begins at conception
it's at least plausible life beans and
conception which me which which leaves
open the door of possibility if you
support abortion you are supporting
uh the genocide
and I don't know about you but I I don't
I don't want I wouldn't want even the
possibility that I'm supporting genocide
let's see
Bradley Williams says Matt as a black
man that grew up in the hood in the late
90s and early 2000s I appreciate you
covering this topic because Gangsta
slash Street slash trap rap music has
been a problem in the last 30 years
since the rise of Death Row Records in
the early 90s white liberals literally
told us and forced us to believe
that this is Black Culture and it's not
another similar comment sins witty says
I got lost in hip-hop for years having
an absent father I gravitated towards
the anger and pain of 1990s rap I became
obsessed with it started rapping and
adopted the culture I still love hip-hop
it only has a fully functioning adult so
I understand the issues with diving too
deep into an into an angry source of art
you have to listen and learn from
mistakes that they're making in their
music not following their footsteps by
the way I'm still an ill rapper
um
yeah it's anger it's it's not just angry
music and and you know rap was not the
first uh example of angry music to come
along obviously
but it's angry it's degraded uh and
that's not the case like if you know
it's not the case necessarily for every
single rap song that's ever been made
uh because at its at its at its
fundamental level I mean rap is you know
supposed to I suppose be poetry set to
music that's what it's supposed to be
it's very lyrical it's beat heavy and
and that's uh that's what it is and
there's no reason why that you know
performing a song which is very
lyrically heavy and um there's a beat in
the background there's no reason why
that is like inherently immoral or
something of course it's not
um
but that just makes what what rap has
become it just makes it all the more
uh outrageous and infuriating going back
to the first comment like it doesn't it
doesn't need to be this way it didn't
have to become this there's no reason
why it has to be this but this is the
decision that was made and it was made
at uh at the highest levels you know in
the music industry because this is the
most profitable this is what they could
sell this is the culture they could sell
uh Eric Wade says love your show Matt I
watch every day a year into marriage my
wife and I learned that she was
medically incapable of conceiving or
bearing children one of my co-workers
said uh that he would have filed for an
annulment because he couldn't consider
himself a real man if he hadn't desired
children I didn't find him particularly
impressive as a person he was a career
desk jockey and his kids were nothing
special they're probably all majoring in
gender studies as I write I enjoyed your
testosterone blinkered blue pill Normie
reminder Matt it's always amusing for a
30-year veteran like myself who
Faithfully served his country in some of
the world's most awful places to be told
that he's not masculine enough so I
guess I might as well shave daily from
now on apparently I'm not man enough to
crawl among your sweet baby gang by the
way the term manosphere was coined by
mostly apolitical thought leaders in the
early days of uh men go their own way it
simply refers to men in a context that
doesn't focus on women okay Eric this is
what frustrates me because if I if I if
I make a general statement
and then I say that there are exceptions
because there are of course exceptions
to most General statements and if you
are an exception then why are you
offended
if if you look at that and say well
that's not the case for me okay well
then it's not the case for you I didn't
I didn't say uh Eric Wade this is this
is true of Eric Wade no I don't know you
I don't know who you are
and so if I'm making a general kind of
observation which is that
most men are called to the Vault the
vocation of fatherhood but not all
you know if that's the general statement
I'm making which I I mean would do you
even disagree with that would you disa
or do you think that a majority of men
should not be fathers
so you're I mean are you advocating for
like essentially the extinction of the
human race because that's what it would
be
so I assume you don't advocate for that
which means you agree with my general
statement yet you're still taking
offense why
I then said that even men who are not
called
to have biological children
are still called to a life of paternal
service in some other capacity so you've
just you've skipped over that part of it
so in fact yeah I do think that every
man is called the fatherhood
for most men that's going to be
fatherhood in the traditional biological
sense of the term
but not for every man there are other
ways to be a father
um I gave one example which is the
religious life it's not the only example
but that's what every man is called to
do a life of paternal service in some
capacity which is just another way of
saying that no man is meant to live a
life entirely focused on himself and
serving only himself no man is supposed
to live a life like that
now you're telling me that you uh have a
30-year veteran so you obviously have
not lived a life like that a life that
is focused entirely on serving the self
so again it's all the more reason why
you're in why uh you uh
you know you you fall into the this the
the the second general statement which
is that all men are called to a life of
service
so I'm just not sure why what what the
issue is here
um okay
Kim says this logic can be applied to
all media including action movies not
everything has to be about the culture
War these young men were tragically
murdered simply for being at the wrong
place in time well that's strange and
it's a weird coincidence isn't it
rappers are constantly at the wrong
place in the wrong time while country
stars are like they never have that
problem
pure luck I guess or maybe the genre
openly Advocates criminality and
violence and the rappers themselves live
lives of criminality and violence in a
culture of criminality and violence and
that's how they so wine so often wind up
in the wrong place because the entire
culture that they exist in and have
helped to create
is wrong
there's that possibility
and finally lady Studio says write a
book about violence thumbs up write a
movie about violence thumbs up right a
country song about violence thumbs up
right pop songs about violence thumbs up
write rap songs about violence you're
glorifying violence
rap rock and metal are the only genres
deemed unacceptable when they have
lyrics about violence
well this is just really stupid I'm
afraid to say first of all
as we talked about
um these forms of media are not all
created equal they are different
and they they affect us in different
ways you know a song
can totally change your mood in like 90
seconds okay that's how quickly it works
a book
can't do that even movies and shows
can't do that to the same extent I mean
they can't affect your mood any any form
of media can but but uh they're not
going to do it as quickly and
efficiently
and with the same kind of power that a
song does
and I'm not just talking about moods
here um but I'm simply pointing out the
power that music has to sway us to move
us and it's silly to deny that
also these rap songs they're not just
about violence okay over the weekend I
watched All Quiet on the Western Front
on Netflix which is an excellent film
highly recommended and it is about
violence at least in part it's about
World War One and the Hopeless brutality
that these young men endured it's it's
about that
it um shows that it portrays that it's
not promoting it it's not glorifying it
quite the opposite it's actually an
anti-war film and you so you don't leave
the film
itching to go jump into a you know a
trench and get into some trench warfare
you don't leave it feeling like World
War One was a fun romp in the Sun
the film is about violent events it
portrays the violent events it doesn't
promote it okay what about these rap
songs that we're talking about well they
actually actively promote the violence
they try to make it seem cool the
rappers are bragging about their violent
exploits the crimes they commit and so
on kids are
um their kids are not going out to
emulate German soldiers in World War One
they are in fact emulating rappers and
they're emulating everything about them
the way they dress the way they talk
um they do what they do they carry
themselves in the same way they adopt
the same sets of values
emulating every aspect of them
why because again music is extremely
powerful it's it gets right to the core
of a human being it sways and it moves
people in ways that other forms of media
don't
and the rap industry again generally
speaking has used this power to actively
explicitly glorify the worst forms of
human behavior
so that's the difference
you know now that it's officially
November some people believe that
they've um and they have now immediate
authorization to begin Christmas
festivities I could talk about how wrong
these people are but regardless of how
you feel there is no bad time to give a
gift as long as that gift is from our
store and especially if it is a walrus
you all saw the transformation I
underwent when I received mine going
from a broken husk of a man to the
cheerful optimistic wildly approachable
social butterfly that you all know me to
be today well you can have the same
transformation if you go to
dailywire.com shop to bring home your
very own cuddly walrus or spread the
love and get a second for a friend
speaking of Christmas Christmas is
usually December 25th but this year it's
coming early because not only is a red
wave going to wash over this country and
save it from the tyrannical left but
there's also a ton of new daily wire
plus content for you to enjoy starting
with new episodes of Jordan Peterson's
new series on marriage this episode is
all about negotiating or I should say
learning the proper way to negotiate
Kenneth Owens also has a brand new
episode of her show taboo featuring
special guest and multi-platinum selling
musician M.I.A you'll hear about her
rise to fame and being canceled for
speaking out about vaccine mandates
among other topics then there's Ben
Shapiro's Sunday special releasing uh
this Sunday Ben sat down with Tennessee
governor Bill Lee to chat about school
choice fighting through cover policies
his experience on a Women's Health
Clinic board and and much more last up
tonight at 7 pm Central daily wire plus
is releasing the documentary film my
dinner with Trump which is behind the
curtain it's just behind the curtain
look at the former president and his
closest advisors as they dine together
and his private club at Bedminster
regardless of how you may feel about the
man this is truly Donald Trump as the
media would never show you and certainly
nothing like this exists or has ever
existed on the right so yes it's a huge
week here and if you're not yet a member
there's never been a better time to join
go to dailywire.com Walsh to become a
member today now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
you know various Saints in the early
church are accredited with declaring
that hell is paved with the skulls of
Bishops Saint John chrysostom was even
more descriptive he wrote the road to
hell is paved with the bones of priests
and monks and the skulls of Bishops are
the lampposts that light the path now
his point was not that all leaders in
the church are bad but rather that they
are called to be very good to be
virtuous and Noble and if they fail if
they don't live up to their calling if
they choose cowardice and Corruption
over courage then the consequences for
the flocks that they are misleading are
dire just as the consequences we can
assume that they will personally face a
judgment day will be dire as well and I
thought about that uh chrysostom quote
yesterday when I read about Irish Bishop
Ray Brown who is the subject of today's
daily cancellation The Story begins as
Roger reports this week in the American
conservative with an old priest named
father Shady in the Diocese of Kerry in
Ireland father shahe stood in front of
his congregation over the weekend
and said that churches need to start
talking about the reality of sin and he
then mentions certain sins that have
gained Mass approval in society
including promiscuity sex before
marriage homosexual sex transgenderism
abortion
here's the relevant portion of that
sermon
what is so sad today is you rarely hear
about Sin but it's rampant it's rampant
and we see it for example in the
legislation
of our governments we see it in the
promotion of abortion we see it for
example in the in the example of this
lunatic approach of transgenderism we
see for example in the promotion of sex
between two men or two women that is
sinful that is mortal sin
and people don't seem to realize it but
it's a fact it's a reality and we need
to listen to God about it because if we
don't then there's no hope for those
people
and so God is also telling you and me
today look you have a responsibility to
seek out those who are lost you have a
responsibility to call people to an
awareness of the fact that sin is
destructive sin is detrimental and sin
will lead us to hell
when we when we honor the Saints on the
first of this coming month we honor
people who are Saints why are they
Saints because they're repented and
because they start forgiveness
as somebody said one time Heaven is full
of converted Sinners and so today God
says to us I have come to call sinners
but if you don't admit you're a sinner
then you're not listening to my call and
I can't do anything for you because it's
a two-way street now there are people
you see who won't like to hear what I'm
saying but the day you die you will find
out what I'm saying is not what I
invented it's not what I came up with
it's what God is saying
well that was all very uh Catholic it
was a completely accurate summary of
official Catholic teaching on sexual
morality but if we've learned one thing
it's that a Catholic Church is no place
for Catholicism especially not in
Ireland and that's why Bishop Ray Brown
responded by immediately throwing his
priest under the bus and groveling for
forgiveness from those who were offended
to encounter Catholicism in a Catholic
Church Brown posted the following
statement to the diocese website he said
I am aware of the deep upset and hurt
caused by the contents of the homilies
in question delivered over the weekend I
apologize to all who were offended the
views expressed do not represent the
Christian position the homily at a
regular weekend Parish mass is not
appropriate for such issues to be spoken
of in such terms I regret that this has
occurred while a parish pilgrimage to
the Holy Land is taking place the gospel
of our Lord and Savior Jesus Christ is a
gospel of love and ever proclaims the
Dignity of every human person it calls
on us all to ever have total respect for
one another this fundamental Christian
teaching was beautifully proclaimed in
the book of wisdom at Mass last Sunday
and then the second reading and in the
gospel of the Beatitudes at mass today
November 1st the Feast of All Saints I
quote the three passages
uh and they quotes them yes you love all
that exists you hold nothing of what you
have made in abhorrence you spare all
things because of all things uh are
yours Lord lover of life you whose
imperishable spirit is in us all that's
wisdom think of the love that the father
has lavished on us
by letting us be called God's children
and that is what we are and then blessed
are the gentle they shall have the Earth
for their Heritage Matthew chapter five
okay
so let's let's start by reiterating a
basic point
agree or disagree with the sermon
the fact remains that it was fully in
line with Christian teaching contrary to
Bishop Brown the priest was indeed
articulating the Christian position if
you don't want to hear the Christian
position then you should not be in a
Christian Church nobody is forcing you
to be there you have not been dragged to
church against your will or marched in
the doors at gunpoint right those who
allegedly experienced deep upset and
hurt by a basic articulation of biblical
principles
deserve to have their feelings utterly
dismissed okay it's like going to a
steak restaurant and then complaining
because the menu Isn't vegan you can't
expect an establishment whether it's a
restaurant or a church to accommodate
your demand that the establishment
abandoned its core Mission and purpose
for your sake you might as well go to a
scuba diving instructor and insist that
he teach you how to play guitar doesn't
make any sense speaking of guitar
lessons this reminds me of a Ricky
Gervais joke that James Corden actually
stole this week Gervais pointed out the
absurdity of people who come to your
your page on Twitter and get offended by
the opinions you're expressing there as
he remarked it's like it's like getting
offended
by a notice on a bulletin board
advertising guitar lessons because you
personally don't want to play guitar
okay well if you're not interested then
just move along why is that so difficult
bringing it back to the church for a
second
the problem in so many churches today is
precisely that they have done nothing
but accommodate churchgoers who don't
want to be at church now it's one thing
to welcome those who are skeptical or
dubious or hesitant that we should do
it's another to drive Christianity out
of your church just so that you can
attract people into it who hate
Christianity you've just defeated the
very purpose of welcoming them in the
first place
so you could brag about oh we got him in
the door well so what you got them in
the door for what you have nothing to
offer them and also you're not actually
getting them in the door this way it's
not even working
you have expanded your church supposedly
by abolishing it you haven't just opened
the doors wide you've Torn Down the
Walls and you've invited the stragglers
to come stand in the rubble with you and
sing Kumbaya
but of course this is how it works on
the left they are not satisfied to let
Christianity be Christianity you have to
rip it down destroy it as Ben Shapiro
says they are transgressives not
progressives though I still kind of like
the um the term Progressive because as
I've often said
leftism does progress in the same sense
that cancer progresses it eats away it
poisons it destroys
as to the rest of this weakling Bishop's
pathetic self-flagellating statement you
know he says that mass is not an
appropriate place for these issues to be
discussed he's wrong again
couldn't be more wrong it is the most
appropriate place for them to be
discussed
the congregation sitting in the pews
they've lived each day of the preceding
week in a culture of sin they've been
surrounded by sin they've been inundated
with messages promoting sin they live in
a society that carries out a constant
assault on virtue and and goodness you
know that that's the reality that
they're dealing with every moment of the
day
we often hear that pastors ought to meet
people where they are and yes I agree
and that's where they are they are
living in the muck and the filth trying
to keep their head above the surface
this reality needs to be acknowledged it
needs to be confronted it needs to be
dealt with
what good are you as a leader what
purpose do you serve who do you serve if
you will not do this if you won't help
your flock navigate
the world that they've been given
and what about love and dignity as the
bishop mentions yes it is our job as
Christians to love people
and to defend the inherent Dignity of
the human person
well you don't achieve either of those
goals by leaving people to flounder in
their sins
you certainly can't preserve human
dignity By ignoring some of the most
Insidious attacks on human dignity that
the world has ever seen
like abortion
or the trans agenda which isn't waging a
nuclear war on human dignity
a person who rejects their own identity
who rejects themselves also rejects
their human dignity
because a person cannot have dignity
without first having a self and the
trans agenda the leftist agenda in
general teaches him to deny his self not
deny himself in the way that Christ
calls us to but deny his selfhood his
identity as a self in favor of some
imagine new self
that can never actually be attained
so yes the priest was not only speaking
truth and outlying Catholic teaching but
he was performing an act of love and
service and defending the human dignity
that cowards like Bishop Brown have long
since surrendered to the spirit of the
age
and that is why Bishop Brown is today
canceled
that'll do it for us today uh talk to
you tomorrow have a great day Godspeed
[Music]
John Bickley here daily wire
editor-in-chief wake up every morning
with our show morning wire where we
bring you all the news that you need to
know in 15 minutes or less join me and
my co-host Georgia Howe for daily
coverage of all the biggest stories on
morning wire
foreign
[Music]